gilles emmanuel jaquet bonjour
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
alors on le disait la france et le
royaume uni vont donc plaider à l'onu
pour la création à kaboul d'une zone
protégée une zone qui permettra à la
poursuite des opérations humanitaires
très concrètement quelles mises en place
avec qui qu'est ce qu'on en sait
aujourd'hui
alors c'est un peu le flou puisque la
france et la grande bretagne vont déjà
de leur initiative proposée au conseil
de sécurité une discussion sur justement
la création d'une zone sécurisée visant
à faciliter les évacuations par la suite
les talibans ne l'entendent pas de la
même oreille on va dire puisqu'il
considère qu' étant les nouveaux maîtres
du pays c'est à eux que revient
d'assurer la sécurité de la capitale et
à l'aéroport et les talibans ont parlé
d'une reprise après le 31 août de des
vols réguliers ce qui est un peu aussi
on pourrait dire très précoce une
déclaration de leur part a et il y a
aussi
des rumeurs ou des informations même
retrouvé dans la presse qui font état de
discussions entre la turquie et les
talibans et la turquie proposerait aux
talibans de d'assurer la sécurité à
l'aéroport et de soutenir leur offre un
tour aux vols réguliers les talibans
demandent en échange d'une
reconnaissance par la turquie de leur
gouvernement alors donc l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir poursuivre les évacuations par
la suite alors si les talibans s'y
opposent à cette seule zone est ce que
cette mise en place rs mais néanmoins
faisable pour la france et le royaume
uni sachant qu emmanuel la crau emmanuel
macron l'a affirmé il souhaite dialoguer
avec les talibans
tout à fait alors emmanuel macron soit
avec les talibans on imagine qu'il
souhaiterait voir
personnel militaire peut être franc
série
dix duels ou occasionnels présentes sur
place pour assurer ces évacuations et ça
ça sera très difficile à mettre en place
puisque pour les talibans ont aucune
troupes occidentales ou à rester sur le
territoire afghan est il ce qu'on voit
derrière cette requête française c'est
une crainte aussi des pays occidentaux
une crainte quant à la sécurité à
l'aéroport de kaboul puisque vous avez
vu qu'il ya eu une attaque terroriste de
l'état islamique jeudi et là encore
récemment des roquettes qui ont été
tirées dans le secteur de l'aéroport
sans compter évidemment
la taille de drones ch'ti qui a fait des
dégâts matériels mais aussi des pertes
civiles donc pour l'instant la situation
à kaboul n'est pas stable et ça ça
empêche évidemment la reprise des vols
commerciaux réguliers alors le président
français qui dit craindre un veto de la
russie et la chine sur la question de
cette zone protégée pour quelles raisons
alors
la russie ne pourrait prendre un veto en
invoquant des différentes de raisons
notamment le fait que les talibans sont
le nouveau pouvoir qui exercent de facto
le contrôle du pays et que c'est à lui
de mettre en place
les processus d'évacuation par la suite
où la reprise des vols normaux en lien
et en soutien avec des gouvernements
occidentaux mais sans que les
gouvernements occidentaux
n'interfère alors la russie et la chine
pouvaient poser aussi un veto pour
rappeler aux occidentaux leur veto
précédent
dans le cadre de conflits au
moyen-orient leur veto qui avait pu
bloquer des décisions russe ou chinoise
il faut bien comprendre maintenant que
les occidentaux ne seront plus les
redire la première puissance en
afghanistan ils ont dû céder la place à
la russie et à la chine c'est un peu un
retournement de situation alors les
états unis et les alliés occidentaux qui
doivent échanger sur la suite de la
situation en afghanistan sur l'avenir de
afghanistan aujourd'hui
finalement quels sont les tensions qui
ont émergé ces derniers jours avec ces
situations en afghanistan entre les
états unis et les alliés notamment le
royaume-uni la france
alors il y a eu mais à un moment aussi
la
demande de la part de certains pays
occidentaux comme la france fait les
américains
essayent de garder des troupes après le
2 mai qui avait été fixé mais les
talibans ont bloqué cela les européens
souhaitent très sûrement voir un soutien
américain à une présence occidentale
résiduelles en afghanistan ou en tout
cas un soutien aux opérations
d'assistance humanitaire est aussi en
relation d'assistance de gouvernement
gouvernement par la suite il semblerait
que pour les états unis l'afghanistan
est d'une certaine manière ce soit une
page tournée en tout cas en ce qui
concerne une implication un peu plus
direct alors que les pays d'europe
occidentale eux semblent vouloir garder
un pied dans le pays y est continue et
d'une manière ou d'une autre à soutenir
le développement du pays mais ce que
l'europe peut compter sur les états unis
pour la suite on pense notamment à
sa de la question de l'accueil des des
afghans qui vont vouloir quitter
l'afghanistan dès détention que ça va ça
va susciter est-ce que
la france l'europe compte sur sur ses
alliés américains sur cette question
alors oui puisque les pays européens
savent qu'ils payent européens sont déjà
confrontées on va dire à une forme de
pression migratoire depuis 2015 et même
depuis avant les pays européens
aimeraient que les états unis prennent
un grand nombre en tout cas un plus
grand nombre de réfugiés afghans afin
d'alléger on pourrait dire le poids qui
pèse sur les épaules des européens c'est
une question sensible en europe
puisqu'il y à déjà depuis 2015 et avant
plusieurs milliers dizaines de milliers
d'afghans qui sont arrivés en europe et
les chiffres pour la suite on pourrait
il n'y a pas de projections précises
mais on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait
d'importants nombre aussi d'afghans qui
arrive en europe et pour beaucoup
d'européens c'est un peu avec une
question problématique al'approche
d'élections dans des contextes de
chômage du coc vie ça peut effectivement
générer des tensions et en satin en
europe à ce que les états unis prennent
aussi lu égard à leur place prennent
plus de réfugiés afghans pour conclure
en un mot le président joe biden
finalement très critiquée aujourd'hui
c'est un échec total pour lui
il est vrai qu'il ya des critiques
évidemment de dans le parti républicain
à son encontre mais aussi au sein du
parti démocrate et certains aux
etats-unis dans la presse des partis
républicains lui reprochent des
déclarations un peu légère peut-être par
rapport à la situation actuelle et aussi
aux évacuations au cas où ce qui a pu
régner autour de ces évacuations et vous
avez certes un groupe aux etats-unis
aussi proche encore une fois des
républicains mais aussi les démocrates
qui appelle un soutien à la résistance
anti talibane certains considèrent que
le président bart hayden a abandonné les
alliés ardente et qu'il n'aurait
peut-être pas tenues assez compte des
rapports de renseignements faisant état
de ce qu'il pourrait se produire avec
l'avancée des talibans merci beaucoup
gilles emmanuel jacquet pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes chargé de cours en
relations internationales analyste à
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève